bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors un retrait qui
préparent au retrait total
à partir de là l'armée régulière afghane
sera seul sur le terrain est elle prête
juste avant de répondre à votre question
à un coup d'oeil sur l'histoire de spa
au 19e siècle l'armée britannique s'est
retirée au xxème siècle armée soviétique
s'est retirée au 21ème siècle armées
américaines se retirent quel pays
alors oui et non elle est prête dans la
mesure où elle est organisée elle est
armée mais à les talibans une tactique
n'est ce pas de guerre asymétrique
donc voilà une armée régulière n'est pas
forcément prêtera à prata fla c'est
vraiment une difficulté qui se profile
et donc les américains à les états unis
ont pris des décisions de garder une
présence militaire autour de
l'afghanistan
donc soit par l'intermédiaire de leur
flotte dans l'océan indien est aussi
dans des pays de proximité à le
secrétaire d'état à la défense des états
unis a échangé pas plus tard qu'hier
avec le ministre des affaires étrangères
d'ouzbékistan qui est un des trois pays
proches donc frontière commune de
l'afghanistan au nord il est dit qu'avec
ce retrait les talibans vont reprendre
le pouvoir à kaboul gaz affirme
d'ailleurs contrôlé quelques districts
de la ville
retour donc à la case départ dans ce
contexte là à quoi aura servi
la présence militaire américaine en
afghanistan nous avons commencé par
l'histoire et bien continuons n'est ce
pas il y à il ya 30 ans à l'armée
soviétique s'est retiré en 1989
en 1994 le parti communiste a perdu le
pouvoir et en 1996 les talibans sont
arrivés donc est ce que l'histoire va se
répéter à on ne se baigne jamais deux
fois dans le même fleuve donc les choses
peuvent être différentes
les talibans ont une influence fortes
effectivement en province a beaucoup
moins forte dans les villes qui ont le
commerce qui ont les écoles à qui ont
acquis une certaine forme de liberté
d'expression dans les médias donc là il
ya deux mondes qui peuvent s'affronter
et puis n'oublions pas que il n'ya pas
que les talibans il ya aussi l'état
islamique qui a à sa propre stratégie
acquis et d'intervenir en particulier à
sur les territoires ou dans les
institutions où il ya des musulmans
chiites
concrètement aujourd'hui dans quel état
l'armée américaine l'afghanistan bien
écouté depuis 20 ans comme julian et de
signaler il y a eu une action en
particulier auprès des villes là où il
ya des populations importantes donc il
ya eu un essor de l'éducation en
particulier bien sûr à destination des
jeunes filles et des jeunes femmes donc
qu'ils se sont mis à travailler il ya
une transformation dans les villes de la
situation afghane par rapport à
l'histoire afghane beaucoup plus
conservatrices donc dans les campagnes
comme je signalais précédemment il y a
eu aussi un essor il y à des économies
qu'il y a des richesses en afghanistan
il y à du minerai de fer il ya luminette
cuivre il y à d'autres ressources
potentielles mais il faut pour cela de
la stabilité et un pouvoir qui pense au
développement économique
un pouvoir même rôle
je quitte ans au bien-être de son peuple
ce qui n'est pas forcément le cas on le
voit d'ailleurs dans d'autres pays
l'iran alors à sa soeur annie a proposé
aux talibans de participer au
gouvernement intérimaire ils n'ont pas
donné suite pour l'instant
tel est leur stratégie et les talibans
sont pris effectivement un peu entre
deux feux n'est ce pas ils ont trouvé
plus radicaux plus extrémiste que avec
l'état islamique et donc il y a une
difficulté vis-à-vis de cette existantes
et de cette coexistence
il y a en plus un organisation un comité
donc de consultatif pour réunir
l'ensemble des aides aux banques qui est
maintenant dirigée par abdullah abdullah
qui est l'ancien premier ministre dont
il y a une structure 1 pour que
l'ensemble des parties puissent à
l'exception bien sûr des textes amis
depuis se retrouver et puis il y a les
institutions historiques
la gageure gaffe délire là l'assemblée a
des provinces et des responsables de
provinces donc qui rompt bien sûr un
rôle à jouer dans l'apaisement qui est
souhaité par tous vesper merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes fondateurs du web magazine le
monde décrypté marseille